in Sudan at least nine people are
reported to have been killed in the
capital Khartoum as the army moved in to
break in a sit-in outside its
headquarters thousands have been
protesting there for weeks calling on
generals to hand over power to a
transitional government in April the
military overthrew President Omar
al-bashir after mass protests against
his 30-year rule join me now is a DW
reporter another Sarris was following
the story for us now that the situation
appears to be very volatile in Khartoum
why has the army decided to move in at
this point I think the Army was thinking
that the sit-in will end after two
months now it has been there from April
6th and they were waiting for people
just to you know get bored and lose
interest in saying there - two months
haven't brought anything new and also
because we have now the fasting one and
month of Ramadan and the military
council thought oh and Ramadan it will
be too difficult for people to stay
there it's so hard to people cannot
drink and eat so they would loot an
interest and go home on the other hand
the military council has been visiting
also regional countries and super power
and regional powers like UAE the Arab
Emirates and Saudi Arabia and Egypt and
has been been getting support from these
countries so I think the military
council has now kind of a signal that it
can't proceed with dispersing the city
in and kind of executing its own
politics there but negotiations have
been going for several weeks between the
military and the leaders of the
protesters what is the main sticking
point there why can't they seem to come
to an agreement that would work for both
sides basically it
was broken three dtt negotiations
stalled because the formation of the
council that should be kind of
presidential and council between
civilians and soldiers it was not agreed
upon the soldiers of the military
council wants more soldiers in that
council and the SP a the association of
Sudanese professionals wanted more
civilians in that Council because the
protesters were demanding a civilian-led
Council so this is the main sticking
point and they didn't come to an
agreement do you see this is a turning
point in this whole protest movement
because the protests have widened you
have government work is also going on
protests you have women marching on to
the headquarters of the army is this a
point of no return now it seems that
things are turning into a kind of more
bloody and confrontation of course many
voices of the opposition and the
protesters were saying we don't want
even to negotiate with the Military
Council so until now we have been seeing
kind of a cooperation between the two
entities now people and some people from
their position are saying the military
council is not even legitimate it's we
don't want to negotiate with it so yes
it is a turning point and if this
doesn't get contained soon it can be or
turn in a very bloody situation
absolutely complete breakdown of trust
another else are us from our reporter
was monitoring that story thank you very
much for your assessment